ja ich begrüße alle teilnehmerinnen
teilnehmer zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
auf die lowcost heute ist die erste
sitzung des seminars philosophische
emotions theorien und ich will jetzt ein
bisschen was zur einleitung sagen
technischer art aber auch inhaltlicher
art erstmal das programm der heutigen
sitzung worum geht es eigentlich
ich sage ein bisschen was formales zum
ablauf des seminars ich sah kurz was zur
prüfungsleistung die sie erbringen
können dann vor allem inhaltliches zum
seminar dem seminarplan werde ich ganz
kurz erläutern und wir machen am ende
dann eine einstiegs diskussion in die
problematik der emotion anhand des
werkes von immanuel kant erst mal was
zum formalen es gibt ein digitales
begleit angebot dieses seminares das
werde ich noch näher erklären es gibt
virtuelle lehre in diesem semester
wieder muss man sagen weil die korona
krise immer nicht vorbei ist hier noch
nicht alle geimpft sind oder wie gewohnt
sind und deswegen virtuelle lehre wird
hier ganz groß geschrieben und virtuelle
lehre kann man jetzt unterscheiden in
synchrone und asynchrone lehre so auch
wie bei der normalen lehre die nicht
virtuell stattfindet was meine ich damit
synchrone lehre ist das was zumindest
wir jetzt hier live über suchen gerade
machen also gleichzeitig live sie sehen
mich ich sehe sie vielleicht nicht höre
sie aber nachher hoffentlich dass es
also synchrone lehre und das synchrone
lehre ist wenn ich zum beispiel die
aufzeichnung dieser sitzung die jetzt
live ist auf youtube stelle und sie sich
die dann im winter machen ein noch
anschauen können oder wenn ich ihn
begleiten noch materialien schicke per
e-mail und zieht es dann eigenständig
die ihre eigenen zeiteinteilung lernen
dass es das zentrum in lehre und ich
möchte von beiden leer typen in diesem
seminar gebrauch machen
also wird die meiste zeit vielleicht
in jeder woche synchrone veranstaltungen
geben dass wir uns hier live sehen auf
so und dann miteinander diskutieren das
wird aber wahrscheinlich jede woche sein
aber es wird ab und zu sein
ich könnte jedes immer an per e mail und
dann wird's auch elemente der
asynchronen lehre geben dann zum thema
synchrone lehre ich hatte schon etwas
gesagt die sendung wird immer
aufgezeichnet und auf meinen
youtube-kanal philo festgestellt und
auch über die extra angeboten hefti
lowcost erschließbar sein
hier ist jetzt mal so dieser empfangs
bildschirm von 4cast susi dass alle auf
youtube sie können einfach mal googlen
den youtube zu casten finden sie den
kanal und er hat schon über 3600
abonnenten abonnenten mit steigender
tendenz
der kanal freut sich über jeden neuen
zuwachs weil das uns die macherinnen und
macher hinter dem kann man natürlich
besonders motiviert
hier sehen sie in ganz kleinen
ausschnitt der aktuellen sendungen auf
die lowcost also wir haben hier ein
video über das chinesische philosophie
was sehr gut angekommen ist seit drei
wochen
ja aber auch vorlesungsaufzeichnungen
von anderen platzieren denn wir haben
auch noch aufzeichnung von anderen
seminaren von mir der vergangenen
semester wie zum beispiel für den
freiheitsbegriff nach kant das alles ist
hier dokumentiert das alles können sie
gerne nachsehen wenn sie wollen dann
noch kurz zu viel oka step die können
sie sich kostenlos für android und apple
phone wenn sie eine seiten herunterladen
hier sehen sie den startbildschirm so
will sich das menü aus und wenn sie
jetzt genau hinschauen oben in diesem
menü dann finden sie hier schon ein
seminar plan unseres seminars wenn sie
darauf klicken dann haben sie denn hier
jederzeit griffbereit das ist ein
seminar für die hosentasche
hier werde ich irgendwann auch noch
weitere texte verlinken als sie können
alles auch über die web sich erschließen
noch kurz und prüfungsleistungen nur
ganz kurz dazu wird es auch noch ein
im merkblatt geben hausarbeit 40.000
zeichen abgabetermin 27 november
september falls es nicht eine verspätung
noch gibt wegen corona aus arbeitete als
pdf format an mich per e-mail vorschläge
ausarbeitet ihm mache ich bekannt
rechtzeitig individuelle absprache mit
mir per email ist möglich schreiben sie
mich einfach an wenn sie fragen haben
wenn es ein thema vorschlagen wollen und
ein merkblatt wie gesagt mach ich gebe
mich bereit
literatur habe ich auch schon jemand in
meinem ersten merkblatt über einen core
box link zugänglich gemacht da wird auch
immer weiter literatur darauf gestellt
werden
so jetzt zum ablauf des seminars zu
beginn gibt es immer eine kurze
einführung bzw wiederholung der letzten
sitzung die wird aufgezeichnet für
youtube zur dokumentation für die us
ikone leere
danach gibt es wie auch heute in den
privaten teil der nicht aufgezeichnet
eine gemeinsame diskussion und die ist
immer historisch systematisch das heißt
wir lesen einerseits klassische texte
der philosophie tradition zum beispiel
von dem amerika wir diskutieren die aber
immer vor dem hintergrund aktueller
fragestellungen und debatten die häufig
der analytischen philosophie entsprechen
dazu werden wir auch in der nächsten und
übernächsten sitzung einen text lesen
aus der stanford enzyklopädie dafür
linke ich den text unten dann im video
youtube video den können sich herr
unterlagen und den kann ich sehr
empfehlen dessen überblicksartikel also
wir wollen immer auch aktuelle debatten
hinzuziehen und mit jahr fall beide
historische wie systematisch aktuelle
texte in eine beziehung bringen und so
gegenseitig letztendlich beleuchten
es wird auch dann in diesen privaten
teil break aussetzung geben wo sie
untereinander diskutieren können
in kleineren gruppen zur fragestellung
gilt davor über an die präsentation ihn
mitteilen
damit wir so ein bisschen die seminar
diskussion zumindest virtuell simulieren
oder modellieren können ja im anschluss
an diese umsetzung kriegen sie von mir
per e mail
eine zusammenfassung des jeweiligen der
jeweiligen seminar sitzung die
wichtigsten ergebnisse
das dient auch zum einer dokumentation
da habe ich dann hinterher auch ein
schönes archiv dann weiß man am ende
auch was hat man eigentlich erreicht und
ich stelle auch die aufzeichnungen auf
die lowcost und sie können die über die
app auch sich anschauen
sie können selbst mir auch per e mail
oder nachher noch in der privaten
diskussion noch weitere themenvorschläge
mitteilen wenn sie jetzt dann nachher im
programm sehen dass da eine philosophin
oder ein philosoph zu kurz kommt den sie
gerne hätten können wir da ganz flexibel
die auch noch mit aufnehmen
so jetzt zu den leitfragen des seminars
erstmal die hauptfrage natürlich was ist
eine emotion dass es die frage und die
sich auch das seminar dreht dann eine
weitere frage ist inwiefern
unterscheiden sich emotionen von gefühl
häufig werden die als synonym gebraucht
aber ich denke eben dass es da gute
gründe gibt es sie zu unterscheiden
dann können emotionen rational sein oder
sind emotionen immer rational lose
gefühle lose emotionen
was bedeuten emotionen damit meine ich
jetzt auf was beziehen sich emotionen
also was ist das objekt von emotionen
wenn sie überhaupt dann objekt haben und
nicht nur subjektive zuständig sind
wie verhalten sich wille und
rationalität in emotionen das ist
natürlich die frage inwiefern emotionen
rational sein können und so weiter und
so fort das sind jetzt also nur ein paar
der möglichen fragestellungen die wir
behandeln wollen in diesem seminar und
zu denen sie natürlich da
des semesters auch eine hausarbeit
schreiben können jetzt komme ich auf dem
seminarplan zu sprechen den ich auch
schon ihn herum geschickt hatte in
diesem merkblatt ich möchte jetzt noch
ein bisschen genauer erläutern also wir
steigen erst mal ein mit der frage was
ist eine emotion lesen da diesen
aktuellen text aus der stent von india
haben wir unterscheiden dann emotionen
gefühle oder in aspekte von gefühlen
motiven und urteilen also emotionen sind
komplexe phänomene die sich weiter
analysieren lassen
dann nachdem wir diesen theoretischen
vorbau uns angeschaut haben sind wir
gerüstet haben wir das instrumentarium
das analytische um klassische theorie
dort texte zu emotionen in der
geschichte der philosophie begreifen zu
können und damit umgehen zu können auf
eine profunde art und wir machen jetzt
mal den anfang immer in verschiedenen
farben ich versuche jede emotion hier
auch eine farbe zu geben
das ist jetzt rein subjektiv dazu mögen
es die andere assoziationen oder
zumindest es ihn haben mitleid habe ich
jetzt mal so hell kühn gemacht hat eine
positive ausstrahlung dann lesen wir von
der unit von auto schopenhauer text über
das mitleid dann blau von dem mann
erkannt seine theorie der achtung
achtung als moralisches gefühl
darauf werden wir auch am ende der
heutigen sitzung noch kurz zu sprechen
kommen im rahmen einer diskussion kam
habe ich jetzt mal so ein bisschen
orange-rot man schmeckt wird der
schamesröte die sich bemerkbar macht da
lesen wir von friedrich schleiermacher
aber auch ganz vor allem von max scheler
ein text über die scham
diese texte stehen bei max scheler
kontext eine anthropologie also der
frage was es überhaupt bedeutet ein
mensch zu sein worin sich mensch die
menschheit des menschliche auszeichnet
gegenüber anderen tieren
der ekel den habe ich jetzt im gegensatz
zur mitleid etwas grell grüner gemacht
so ein bisschen schleim grünen da lesen
jetzt von jean patrick auszüge aus dem
gleichnamigen buch der sie vielleicht
kennen dann verzweiflung habe ich in
schwarz gemacht verzweiflung hat sowas
assoziativ wie ausweglos ist ich weiß
keinen weg mehr
ich bin verzweifelt das ist er gekommen
ist da die haut person die diese emotion
wenn es denn eine ist das müssen wir
auch mal kritische fragen behandelt hat
dann die angst die habe jetzt mal ein
bisschen grau charakterisiert wie der
kicker aber auch martin heidegger in
seiner schrift über seine zeit hat eine
ganz bedeutende analyse der angst
gegeben natürlichen anknüpfung an
kritiker und neid und eifersucht da
wollen wir ein bisschen auf die antike
zu sprechen kam auf platon aristoteles
ich habe ich jetzt grün gemacht grün vor
neid sagt man ja manchmal und zuletzt
die liebe und die habe ich natürlich rot
gekennzeichnet und hier gehen wir auf
augustinus auf hannah arendt und auf
harry frankfurt ein
und wenn sie jetzt selbst noch
vorschläge haben für emotionen oder
klassische texte die sie mit blick auf
emotionen behandeln wollen behandelt
haben wollen können sie mir gerne e
mails schreiben
ich dachte jetzt zb an espinosa oder
antik art die sich dafür auch noch
eigene filme jetzt gehen wir zur
heutigen sitzung also was ist eine
emotion ist da im zentrum
inwiefern unterscheiden sich emotionen
von gefühlen effekten und stimmungen
können emotionen rational sein was
bedeuten emotionen diese fragen haben
sie schon gesehen
und wie verhalten sich mit rationalität
in emotionen wir wollen diese fragen die
unsere ganze seminar lange diskutiert
werden
heute mal kurz an diskutieren und zwar
möchte das jetzt mal hand von kants
begriff der achtung machen das moralisch
gefühlte achtung also inwiefern ist
achtung eine emotion
inwiefern unterscheidet sich die achtung
als emotionen vom gefühl des hungers zum
beispiel in niefern ist achtung ein
gefühl in niefern ist achtung eine
motivation
inwiefern ist achtung einem urteil ein
moralisches urteil
das sind die fragen die wir uns jetzt
heute aber dann auch in der sitzung die
nur kant gilt stellen wollen und jetzt
habe ich hier einen kleinen text auszug
aus seiner grundlegung zum metallica
sitten und kann sagt da über die achtung
mit einer fußnote erstaunlicherweise er
sagt man könnte mir vorwerfen als suchte
ich hinter dem wort achtung nur zuflucht
in einem dunklen gefühle
anstatt durch einen begriff der vernunft
in der frage deutlich auskunft zu geben
allein bin 8 und gleich ein gefühl ist
so ist es doch kein durch einflüsse
ranges sondern durch einen von uns
betrifft selbst gewähltes gefühl und
daher von einem gefühlen der ersten art
die sich auf neigung oder volk bringen
lassen
spezifisch unterschieden als er sagt
hier die achtung ist ein ganz ganz
besonderes gefühl aber nicht durch
einfluss empfangen als alle nicht von
außen von den offizieren werden sondern
ein gefühl was rationales anfang und
betrifft und es stammt aus und selbst
ist es gewillt als die welt heißt es
kommt aus und zählt es ist dort
entstanden
es hat die wurzeln selbst und das
zeichnet sich dadurch aus von einem
antrag gefühl so das ist jetzt mal hier
seine erste charakterisierung ich finde
die in aller kürze trotzdem sehr
spannend weil wir hier schon ganz
verschiedene aspekte von emotionen sehen
also kann sagt die achtung
hat eine nationale seite sie hat auch
eine gefühls seite sie hat zwar selbst
gewirkt und nicht zuletzt sie hat auch
wie wir dann noch sehen werden die rolle
der moralischen motivation wenn wir
nämlich das gefühl der achtung empfinden
dann werden wir zu einer handlung bewegt
und zwar zu einer moralischen handlung
deswegen ist verkannt die achtung als
emotionen wie ich sie bezeichnen würde
ganz zentral vielleicht das zentralste
geführt die zentralste emotion braucht
ja nur mal das als hintergrund sich
sehen also die geschichte der
philosophie auch immanuel kant den man
immer vorwirft er hätte gefühlen oder
emotionen zu wenig bedeutung geschenkt
die ist voll von emotionen und die frage
ist nun wie wir sie verstehen was ist
also eine emotion will jetzt mal ganz
kurz systematisch aufwerfen diese frage
und in einer vorläufigkeit mal versuchen
zu beantworten
diese gedanken von mir die sind jetzt
mal vorläufig die können sich auch noch
ändern durch ihre kritik durch unsere
diskussion im laufe des seminars ich
möchte jetzt einfach nur mal einen
vorschlag machen eine these hier in den
raum stellen also ich glaube wir müssen
emotionen und wir können emotionen
begrifflich von gefühlen von effekten
und verstimmungen unterscheiden
das wird ja in den allerwenigsten fällen
getan wenn sie jetzt gefragt werden was
ist denn der unterschied zwischen
emotionen gefühle sind gefühl oder weg
zwischen effekten stimmung
da wird schwierig und ich glaube aber
dass man doch unterscheiden kann und ich
habe jetzt mal hier seine theorie
entwickelt vordefinierte und zwar würde
ich sagen emotionen eine emotion ist
eine robuste ausdruck integraler
subjektivität es muss jetzt genau
erklären
august meine ich es ist etwas was nicht
nur momentan auftritt an ein zustand der
eine gewisse stabilität hat eine emotion
ist ziemlich klar abgegrenzt und
erstreckt sich auch in einer
hinsicht zeitlich und sie drückt unsere
subjektivität unsere individualität
unserer zustand integral aus das heißt
in seiner ganzheit aus wir sind in
dieser emotion in der emotion sind wir
als ganze letztendlich ausgedrückt als
ganze sichtbar und zwar über eine
gewisse zeit hinweg stabil
also nicht instabil nicht nur einer
kurzen phase im moment sollen in all
gewissen ausstrecken gewissen extension
ein gefühl dagegen ist jetzt etwas was
nicht so sehr aus unserem innersten
vielleicht kommt was nicht unsere
subjektivität integral also ganzheitlich
betrifft sondern es hat immer eine
gewisse äußerlichkeit und es ist auch
nicht erinnere ausdruck komme gleich
noch genauer darauf zu sprechen
ein effekt hingegen ist ein momentaner
ausdruck der integralen subjektivität
also unterscheidet sich von der emotion
so meine theorie dadurch dass er nicht
robust ist der effekt bestand hat
sondern momentan auftritt oder auch
spontan ganz kurzzeitig aber unsere
subjektivität in einer gewissen ganzheit
integrität ausdrücken eine stimmung
schließlich so meine vorläufig these ist
ein robuster ausdruck also nicht nur
momentan ist aber dass längerfristiges
aber nicht unserer gesamten ungeteilten
zur vitalität hast du nur partiell so
wie es auch das gefühl so jetzt ist das
alles natürlich sehr viel und über
unübersichtlichen dazu habe ich jetzt
mein vorschlag zur klassifizierung
entwickelt den wir über das semester
hinweg gerne diskutieren können und das
wird sich bestimmt noch einiges ändern
vielleicht wird sich zeigen dass das
ganze gar nicht tragfähig ist also ich
habe jetzt mal hier kategorien wie
subjektivität und extension access
dass also die ausdehnung hat über
begriffe dann kann man das unterscheiden
die subjektivität als integral also als
ungerührt als ganzheitlich als
vollständig und als partielle als unsere
individualität subjektivität wird
entweder ganzheitlich ausgelegt oder nur
teilweise und auch die extension einer
eines phänomens das wir fühlen es kein
bewusstsein also stabil
längerfristig bestand haben oder nur
momentan in stadt nicht sein so jetzt
haben wir hier als emotionen die würde
ich jetzt sage emotionen hier können sie
das dann sehen die sind integrale treten
uns ganzheitlich aus so wie zum beispiel
jetzt die achtung beachtung empfindet
der ist da ganz motiviert dahinter steht
hinter diesem diese einstellung zeigt
sondern das kant und er ist robust also
es hat bestand es ist nicht nur wie ein
effekt was kurzzeitig auftreten das kann
man jetzt gut vom gefühl abgrenzen
nämlich ein gefühl ist in meinen augen
nicht integral subjektiv sein partiell
und momentan wie zum beispiel hunger gut
ein hunger kann sich schon auch ein
bisschen aus wie ein bisschen
ausstrecken
aber er trifft nie unsere ganze
subjektivität weil es nur ein teil von
ihnen ist es wird etwas in meinem magen
ich kann mich dazu aber auch noch
distanzieren ich gehe da nicht ganz auf
in dem hungergefühl deswegen dieses
nicht integral das gefühl in meinen
augen aber es ist auch nicht so robust
ausgestreckt ist diffus
der hunger dann haben wir den effekt
glaube effekt im affekt sind wir ganz
betroffen also nicht nur an hungergefühl
sondereffekte stärker er betrifft uns
ganzheitliche grundlegende tiefgründige
er ist aber und das hat er wiederum mit
dem gefühl gemein ihr momentan
er ist nicht so robust mord im affekt
sie kennen das da ist man ganz
überwunden in einer gewissen hinsicht da
ist man überwältigt aber eben nur kurz
sei und da wäre ein beispiel oder zorn
und zum schluss stimmung stimmung halte
ich nicht für ein ausdruck unserer
ganzen subjektivität ich halte sie für
etwas partielles aber für etwas
robusteres was ich länger strecke und
die wäre zum beispiel glück oder trauer
ein beispiel das ist jetzt nur ein
vorläufiges thematisierung ich habe es
mal versucht und jetzt können wir anhand
dieser thematisierung noch andere dinge
nämlich zeigen nämlich wir sehen von
diesen ganzen phänomenen hier haben
emotionen und affekt diesen aspekte
integrität also unsere ganzheitlichen
subjektivität
das haben die stimmung und das gefühl
nicht und das können wir jetzt zu
interpretieren dass die integrität
dieses phänomens alle dass wir ganz
betroffen sind als individuen dass die
in der lage sind uns zu motivieren wenn
wir ganz integral betroffen sind wenn
die emotionen oder der effekt ein
ausdruck unserer selbst ist und zwar
ganzheitlich dann haben wir die stärkste
motivation weil es uns in unserer
gesamtheit trifft und das wäre auch die
achtung nach kant wo wir als ganzes
individuum als vernunft wesen daneben
plötzlich orientiert werden
und wir haben dann noch einen weiteren
aspekt nämlich den der reflexion der
wird dann überhaupt thematisch werden
wir es mit robustheit zu tun haben etwa
ist eine emotion ist insofern robust als
sie sich eben länger erstreckt also
nicht nur zerfällt wie ein gefühl und
diese konstanz diese robustheit der
emotionen die erlaubt es uns um eine
folie these darauf zu reflektieren
als es die rational zu verstehen und
diese zwei bedingungen der motivation
und der reflexion die treffen eben nur
auf die emotionen zu deswegen glaube ich
dass emotionen etwas besonderes sind und
dass wir sie eigens in einem seminar
behandeln sollten
da ist jetzt wirklich nur vorläufig also
zusammengefasst emotionen sind komplex
ist subjektiv expressive zustände
emotionen sind etwas was sich ausdrückt
da drückt sich unsere ganzheitliche
subjektivität aus und es empfehlen wir
erfahren nicht nur etwas es fehlt nicht
nur als etwas zu sondern wir drücken
etwas ausholen sie drinnen die gesamte
stabilität aus und sie motivieren und es
dadurch auch zu handlungen die sind
stabil die emotionen sind nicht nur ins
titan und tann wie zum beispiel perfekt
und sie erlauben damit reflexion
rationalität das ist zb bei einem effekt
nicht der fall
effekte die überwältigen uns deswegen
sind wir da nicht immer ganz zu recht
deswegen haben sie nicht eine gewisse
rationalität es haben aber emotionen wie
ich glaube schon